[Music]
so we are going to
ireland to do a financial freedom
challenge i'm going with my wife a first
time
amanda's been out on a financial freedom
challenge with me amanda come on
how are you feeling about the challenge
you're excited yeah so we're leaving the
kids behind they don't know we're going
yet
and we're gonna go for like what like a
week yeah you're gonna go for like a
week
have we planned much for this no we
don't even know where we stay have we
studied the irish market
nope we have not studied the irish
market we have not planned for this trip
this is a
almost a spontaneous ff challenge as
always
are you um what are you expecting for
the week i don't know
hopefully hopefully um
good houses good deals yeah do you
reckon that i'll manage to become
financially free in ireland
yeah i think so you reckon that well are
you confident
we're going on an ff challenge in
ireland
we're actually not i'm taking on a
surprise holiday
to belgium and paris
[Music]
looking at the pictures of yeah where
we're gonna be
[Music]
what are you thinking i'm not like
excited
as um as in in what way it doesn't look
like particularly
it just looks like stoke-on-trent it
doesn't look like anything special
anyway have you got my passport yeah
have you got your passport
yeah check because just in case we need
to go to dublin
it's amanda leeds here and we are in the
car on our
way to belfast island with samuel
uh i'm joining him this time for his ff
challenge there
and it's just dawned on me that i mean i
don't know
how much of it to begin with by saying
it's gonna be
fun yeah okay yeah yeah since you've
been looking at the weather
i've been looking at the weather and
it's like
not gonna be as nice as where we are now
so
it's raining it's a bit of a downgrade
in terms of weather
but what you gotta remember is though
this is not a holiday this is our
we're gonna be working hard we're gonna
be doing deals
yeah yeah yeah no it's i think i think
it'll be exciting to see you
in action because i haven't actually
seen you doing an ff challenge i've just
always seen the videos
yeah so how much preparation have we
done about the irish market and about
ireland
zilch zero we don't even know which part
we don't even know
what island or whatever we're gonna be
in we don't even know if we're gonna end
up in dublin
we've got our passports just in case we
don't know if it's pounds or euros
in ireland we've been only been into
island once for one day because we have
to go and pick up a parcel once from
ireland
that's it yeah what strategy do you
think we should use in ireland like do
you think we should do lease options
deal packaging brr like how on earth
going to ireland with no money are we
going to become financially free
i really don't know i really really
don't know but lease options always seem
to be
i think it's like a good a good strategy
in most places because there's always
going to be people that yeah lots of
negative equity in belfast
yeah so i think i think that might be
the one that we
end up using but i don't know i think so
and how confident are you on a scale of
one to a hundred
that i am going to be able to become
financially free in a week in belfast or
in ireland
90 95 only 95. not even 99.
okay well it could be 99. how convenient
i'm very confident
that i'm gonna i'm gonna do a deal and
make some money in the next seven days
oh
a hundred percent you just know it's
gonna be yeah it's gonna happen the
first time
when he was going to sheffield i
remember i cried
because i didn't know how long he was
going to be aware for he was just kind
of like
i've blocked out i think it was a few
months four months
he blocked out four months and he just
said i'm going to sheffield
to do an ff challenge and however long
it takes me to become financially free
is however long it's going to take so
then i was a little bit upset yeah
because you thought i could be gone for
months
yeah so i didn't i didn't know so i was
a bit upset the first time i remember
you saying to me i hope to see you back
because now for people that watched it
probably just thought oh i was being so
dramatic because they're just like
samuel did it like that
in a week wasn't it yeah so but i didn't
know that at the time
so now i've seen him do a few i know
that he's definitely very capable and
competent
so yeah so i have no doubts that you
will
do what we're setting out to do so which
is to make some money do some deals
in ireland from scratch with no no
market knowledge or anything
yep exactly and i'm excited to see you
doing it
awesome let's go island
[Music]
jump i am scared of you
and i'm the brains of the operation so
yesterday i don't think you are
so we're going to ireland and we're
going to be doing an ff challenge with
what i'm going with samuel so
yeah so it's exciting
i'm really excited to go to ireland and
i'm really excited to
be with amanda so my question to you is
amanda if you were going to ireland on
your own and i wasn't with you now
what would what would you be thinking
about the ff challenge
sir if you if i was going to ireland on
my own without you because you have a
feeling i'll probably be the main one
yeah
yeah you'll be the main one i personally
would have done lots of preparation i
wouldn't just jump into something blind
like you do
so i would have at least had a look
at what kind of properties on rightmove
are available
so just kind of got myself familiar with
i even think right move is a thing in
ireland
or is it not no then i'd be very screwed
i don't know i don't know what i would
i don't know what i'd do then but i
definitely would have just done a little
bit of research on
i don't know different areas see what
other people are doing in ireland maybe
gone on some groups and
i don't know put it out there so
yeah you were going on your own and you
had to do the ff challenge
would you be feeling a bit nervous now
yes i'd be very nervous i'm at the
moment i'm really chilled because
you're the one everything's on you it's
down to you to ensure that you get
financially free um this week so
i'm just like oh here for the ride but
i'm not really
it's not on me so i'm definitely very
chilled if i was going by myself i would
be really nervous
especially if i was filming it if i was
going by myself with no camera and had
all the time in the world to do it then
it'd be fine
but filming it you know and documenting
it as we go
i think that would be quite
nerve-wracking it's depressing that the
weather here
is like so glorious it's really nice and
i'm wearing this jumper but it is
really warm outside it's 23 degrees the
sun is shining how fast it's currently
17 degrees and raining
great i'm not looking forward to being
cold but
it is what it is you know we'll just go
and make it happen what way
yeah mainly me
[Music]
uh what's happening amanda so we're just
that news house you're gonna get your
stuff
and then we're gonna hit the road to i
don't even know where we're driving to
after this
we're going to head down to ireland but
how do we get to ireland
uh we're after us new isn't it coming
with us
yeah look at the camera isn't it yeah of
course of course
why is nico in with us because he's the
man with the plan with the camera
oh that's true am i missing something
you're missing something
what the truth is news not coming
and we're not going to ireland where are
we going
we're driving somewhere else instead are
you joking
no are you jerking you are you jerking
we are going to paris
no enough oh my god
you are checking him you're joking no
way are you joking firstly we're gonna
go to belgium and get some chocolate
and then we're gonna go to paris to
celebrate our anniversary
oh my gosh i never spilled it
oh my god
yeah you knew this and you didn't see
anything and the weather is good
it's 35 degrees celsius
are you excited oh my goodness
oh my gosh so i've booked the ferry
the ferry leaves in two hours so we need
to shoot
and we when we get to belgium we're
going to get you some chocolate i could
actually cry
oh bear i'm gonna get you some chocolate
cause we've been married five years that
is so
sweet so we're gonna have chocolate
uh tonight when we get to belgium and
then we'll be at the eiffel tower for
the anniversary
oh my gosh oh
i never expected it like oh my gosh
you surprised me so much
happy anniversary
i was hoping that she wouldn't catch on
she didn't catch on so now
we're going to go down we're not doing
an ff challenge sorry ireland i will
come into an ff challenge in ireland one
day
but right now i've got an anniversary to
celebrate with my wifey
honestly i'm so shocked i didn't expect
it at all
like at all i'm so shocked
have you ever been to paris no i've
never been to barry you've been to
belgium
get out of here
[Music]